well I mean you know we've already
broken so many eggs being able I
wouldn't even be able to figure out how
we could d publicize that's not work but
do you publicize our public ownership
because it's so distributed now we're
sort of even if you didn't want to get
it wanted we've got it the real issue to
me is whether or not it's going to be
run in a way which is even basically in
accord with the public interest and
there are other hammers but I don't
think they'll ever be put in place for
example federal and corporation law
right now there's state corporation laws
really erase for the bottom where we're
basically Delaware usually leads the
pack and they can't ever do anything so
drastic is to outrage the federal
government into looking at imposing its
will for the SEC although the SEC is
chained and try two times but that's to
me a lot more important than for example
trying to get rid of all public
companies I don't mind futures and
options provided their traded on
recognized exchanges the real problem is
that you have a lot of strange little
one off dealers making and you know
creating these from these crazy little
instruments and then telling you what
the value is but the thing is what
people forget is is just because a
dealer tells you it's that some
instrument is worth something that's not
a market a market to me is a centralized
entity where commodities or instruments
financial instruments with what the
definite characteristics are traded but
we've just got this this huge mess and
that and and it may be and i really
don't know because i have not read the
new financial bill but it may be that
there are places in there which which
would achieve some of the movement to
recognize exchanges but usually what
happens is
either because of the lobbyists or
because of the extravagantly intelligent
Wall Street lawyers that that real or
perceived loopholes will be exploited to
avoid the more obvious in basic of these
of these changes so I'm without and
without a reinvigorated sec and without
an attitude that the government's going
to go after financial malefactors which
I haven't really seen I mean think about
what happened have you seen have you
seen a lot of people going to jail or
even starting to know you're not going
to because what happened was that the
regulations and the law were such that
you could basically get away with murder
if you had a good lawyer helping you and
I really one of my great disappointments
the Obama administration to be honest is
that we didn't have a replay what were
called the pecora investigations during
during the New Deal when basically all
of the abuses were were publicized over
many years to engender a widespread
revulsion at what's going on which was
basically what's going on today just
take it back 70 years 80 years and and
we haven't had that so we ended up with
a strange bill that came out that you
know where where is huge and length no
one really knows what's in it and I'm
really worried about it especially if if
it's if we retrench you know if you're
England for example you know their
financial sector is so important to
their country i'm not even sure they
really can make it stick for a long
period of time about trying to make them
you know walk the walk of ethics because
some of the people might just take up
and basically take their capital and go
to Singapore or something and we're
getting to the point where unless we get
control over this financial sector it'll
gets powerful enough where we won't be
able to control it in five years unless
we've really started to make an effort
now I don't I haven't seen it